I guess I'm gonna start with the most
important question did you watch the
game of Thrones finale and what did you
think
don't tell me anything I haven't seen
one episode of Game of Thrones it's good
I'm one of those people that catches up
like maybe four years after the decade
like just watch the shield last year the
entire series that's a great show
credible yes so I will watch Game of
Thrones when it's all done and dusted
and I can just sit down and go through
it like you know and maybe like eight or
900 or stints it's weird it's weird it's
good
I respect it I wish I could say that but
I did watch it and thanks Sophie is
[ __ ] amazing in it that Sophie it's
it's weird it's really the 2d action
episodes the the big fight in there and
the the I guess the anarchic panic and
yeah the filler episode no no that one
great and they then what happens when I
say he goes into panic and there's a
huge that was it amazingly times both
episodes were like just complete action
episodes - no I mean yeah and they were
great they were fantastic they were
brilliant action episodes okay I hear
everything you're saying and Sophie's
growing an age like in fact she's such a
vulnerable volatile character in Dark
Phoenix it's really interesting to see
her being so in control so empowered and
so in control of her faculties as answer
she's amazing and in that actually and
made me feel like she was much older how
much older person than she actually is
but I wish you could see the whole time
he's like this no there's no spoilers
there I can't believe you made it this
planet let's move past that yeah so
there's a line that I love in the movie
that is there's always a speech Charles
or like that you're always sorry and
there's always a speech basically
calling me on my steak I love that line
and and one of them just can you talk a
little bit about working with Simon and
because like those kind of moments for
me they're just so awesome yeah I think
it's fun you know the fans love
that sort of stuff you know it's you
know to have some tongue-in-cheek
moments within something that's dealing
with quite you know serious topic matter
it's always important to let the
audience relax again let a laugh out and
sort of reengage and working with Simon
you know obviously known him first you
know nine years now and since we came on
the x-men sag he's sort of been there
from the beginning so I was writer and
producer so it was really cool and
exciting for him to be director for the
first time and I was I was like I was
wondering why was he going to do this
and he just took to it like a doctor
water he was very relaxed unsaid and
always had a very clear idea of the tone
and how he wanted to present this it was
very important for him to return to the
Dark Phoenix story because he felt like
last and even though it's supposed to be
about her it was more about the male
characters around her and he wanted this
you know Sophie's centerpiece here and
and it's her story and rightly so and so
it was really cool to sort of you know
have that arc with him you know to sort
of make a sort of full circle of him
directing what could be our last
installment uh-huh I have a bunch of
Twitter questions from people and so let
me jump since I only have so many
minutes hopefully do you have a favorite
Michael performance and do you have a
favorite McAvoy performance oh I think
hunger and shame she even had 12 years
of slave man you're just really good
you're really good you're almost really
good bit those were so raw and sort of
those movie survived on the act and
quite a lot you know I mean that's
unfair actually that's unfair because
he's an amazing director as well and
they did incredible stuff but a big
element of why those movies work is
because it you massively because he yeah
the first time I guess you know Norris
James was when we were working on band
brothers and I just loved his confidence
and my grace Mormons know I first know
there was a lot of guy he's running
around in green yeah and it's he stood
out he you had at one episode yeah I
always sort of remember that and then I
watched shameless and I was like wow
that's like
this guy's really good and then
atonement and then I think split was a
really good one for you tonight that get
your rocks off and really you know do
all those multiple personalities get
your act on right so yeah it's just but
it was always something you know I was
like that guy it's got something from
that from the beginning when I when I
saw like that first moment and sort of
Band of Brothers Michael when are you
coming back to work good question and
and of towards the end of the summer
I'll be doing a conferee
I heard are you doing wild bunch as well
we'll see we're talking and you know in
talks I understand how that is the
contract being worked out yeah did you
guys do you have any sort of pre
shooting ritual like you do something
before the you know someone says
actually for oh I used to I have a
secret angry angry I'm a mutant I have a
secret thing yeah I for a little while
for a couple of years I would sort of I
try and make myself as tense as possible
before dinner take and then just relax
and because it just made you feel really
relaxed and like it's just [ __ ]
stupid and didn't need to do yeah I got
a something it did work obviously
because anyway then that's off on a
tangent uh what movie have you watched
the most hmm is there a big lebowski Top
Gun I will probably watch Top Gun every
day of the summer holidays when I was 13
12 13 with my mate Martin my gorillas
that and the Goonies we watch that every
day the summer holidays we alternated
between the two so I've probably watched
that 20 times
I'm gonna [ __ ] knees yeah I would go if
we're going that far back maybe Fletch
oh yeah but but Big Lebowski more recent
years I'm already out of time I had a I
gotta go I have a million other things
but listen congratulations thank you for
real and thank you so much for your time